so why do we have all these AI
technologies but no real AI we have
machines that do things that we used to
think only humans could do but nothing
like the flexible general-purpose
intelligence that each of you uses to do
every one of these things for yourselves
so why not what's the gap well the
neural networks and deep learning that's
driving today's AI is based on simple
equations that were worked out in the
1970s and 80s
to describe the most basic animal
learning think Pavlov's dogs or a rat in
a maze they're finding patterns
detecting associations but they're not
understanding which means it's at most
one small step towards real machine
intelligence real intelligence goes
beyond pattern recognition to modeling
the world explaining and understanding
what we see imagining things we could
see but haven't yet making plans and
solving problems to make those things
real and then building new models as we
learn more about the world the goal of
my work is to reverse-engineer these
human abilities to write down their
equations and then to use that to make
more human-like AI and we're starting
with trying to understand how children
learn and think because they're the
original model builders and we are still
very far from having AI that's as
intelligent as even a one and a half
year old but imagine if we could get
there imagine if we could build AI that
grows into intelligence the way a person
does it starts like a baby and learns
like a child it may not be our only
route to AI but it could be our best bet
because think about it a human child is
the only learning machine in the known
universe that reliably demonstrably
grows into human level intelligence
starting for much less and we know that
even small steps towards this goal
scaled up could be big so we're starting
with the most basic common sense that's
in every child and no AI what we call
intuitive physics like you see here for
playing with blocks stacking up cups or
what we call intuitive psychology that
lets even young children like for
example this little guy in the back here
see what somebody's doing and understand
what they're doing and why what their
goals are and how to help them even for
complex actions like this that you've
never seen before now watch this kid
carefully these kids I'm showing you
were just one-and-a-half but imagine if
we could build a
that had this kind of common-sense
intelligence this kind of helpfulness
its kind of helpfulness around the house
it'd be amazing so now for the technical
part to do this we've invented new AI
programming tools called probabilistic
programs which build on but go way
beyond the neural networks that's the
big AI breakthrough you've been hearing
about for the last few years and this is
what you're gonna be hearing about in
the next few years if you haven't
already just as one example just in the
last year in 2018 we've used these tools
to give robots a kind of intuitive
physics that lets them do all these
things stack up blocks and play the game
Jenga imagine uses for new tools that
they've never seen before even for
complex actions make sushi or at least
the rice for sushi pour ice water even
learn to walk what's next is model
learning so what would it take for a
robot or a baby to learn an intuitive
physics model learning one of these
probabilistic programs means that your
learning algorithm has to be a program
writing program it's the child is coder
now this kind of learning is much harder
than learning in a neural network but
somehow children do it so a machine can
too and recently we've made a small step
right now we can learn programs that
capture a simple visual concept like
these handwritten characters each of you
can learn thousands of handwritten
characters in many alphabets that you
don't already know and you can learn
each one from just a single example you
don't need hundreds or thousands of
examples to learn just a single concept
like today's machine learning now our
Bayesian program learning system learns
like you do it uses these probabilistic
programs to capture the causal processes
that put ink on the page so action
programs for drawing and writing and
then it can run these programs backwards
to learn the concept most likely to have
produced any one observed character this
lets our system generalize from a single
example and even pass a very simple kind
of Turing test so we can show one
example of a new concept to both humans
and machines and say imagine new ones
draw new instances of that concept can
you tell the difference between the
human and machine before I showed you
try again and here's another chance I
think you can tell my bet is that you
couldn't okay now this is just again one
small step towards more human-like
machine learning but it's scales we can
learn programs that capture the concept
of
chair that can answer questions about
pictures and that can even learn to play
a new video game a hundred or a thousand
times faster than today's deep
reinforcement learning and almost as
fast as a person so looking ahead once
we get to this 18 month-old stage of
intelligence what's next well stage two
is is using that common sense to learn
the most important thing that every
child learns between one and a half and
three language and then stage three is
age three on up to adulthood using
language to learn everything else to
access the full sweep of human knowledge
that builds culturally across
generations and puts you in a position
to contribute new knowledge yourself so
think about it imagine if we could build
AI that learns like that this would be
AI that truly lives in a human world
this would be AI that you could talk to
teach and Trust the way human beings
have always done with each other even
people that were just meeting for the
first time this would be AI that could
make us actually truly smarter and
better off thanks
[Applause]